sie haben es in die usa geschafft sind
aber noch längst nicht am ende ihres
langen weges angekommen ein weg der in
ein besseres leben führen sollen jetzt
führt dieser weg die migranten gruppe
aus fünf erwachsenen und neun kindern
erst einmal durch dichtes gestrüpp über
rutschige felsen und an tiefen
schluchten vorbei immer mit kleinen
kindern auf dem arm zuvor konnten wir
beobachten wie sie mit einem
schlauchboot von schleppern über den
grenzfluss río grande gebracht worden
sind eine illegale eine gefährliche
überfahrt sobald die dämmerung über der
grenzregion einsetzt und zieht jetzt auf
der anderen seite auf der mexikanischen
seite wie ein boot zu wasser gelassen
wurde hinten sieht man hinter den
büschen eine gruppe von migranten die
jetzt sich fertig macht für die
überfahrt nach amerika das ganze ging
sehr schnell zuerst war ein rotes auto
zu sehen das ist ein so genanntes potter
jemand der die gegend erforscht dann
sieht man sofort das boot wird ins
wasser gelassen von den schleusern
formen kjs und jetzt eben der moment für
die auf denen viele dieser migranten
gewartet haben die überfahrt nach
amerika das ganze natürlich hoch
gefährlich die ufer entlang des
grenzflusses sind übersät mit
kleidungsstücken die die flüchtlinge
zurück lassen sie wollen so wenig wie
möglich ballast auf ihrem weg durch den
süden texas bei sich haben die kleidung
zeugt von den vielen migranten die hier
durchkommen tag für tag ein stetiger
strom an menschen aus mittel und
südamerika
es ist ein historischer ansturm
240.000 einwanderer sind es alleine im
mai die von grenzbeamten aufgegriffen
worden sind viele menschen sind schon
ertrunken beide fahrt nach amerika und
wenn man hier die szenen hinter mir
sieht merkt man wie viele menschen das
sind es sind jede nacht überfahrten hier
zu verzeichnen
immer wieder an anderer stelle man
spielt hier natürlich ein wenig katz und
maus mit der border patrol und der
nationalgarde die hier abgestellt ist
die migrantengruppe läuft weiter in
richtung norden ohne zu wissen wo sie
genau sind was ihr nächstes ziel ist es
geht hier hoch in einer steilen klippe
und eine hat gesagt sie wissen haben
keinen plan sie wollen ihr schicksal in
die hände gottes legen wollen schauen
was jetzt passiert auf der
amerikanischen seite natürlich
warten hier beamte der border patrol und
die beamten bringen die gruppe in ein
auffanglager ihr schicksal ungewiss und
gleichzeitig unten im tal überquert das
nächste schlauchboot mit migranten den
grenzfluss
wir fahren rüber auf die mexikanische
seite ein flüchtlingslager von hier aus
versuchen hunderte menschen den legalen
weg über die grenze mit offiziellen
einreise papieren die sie von hier aus
beantragen unterstützt werden sie dabei
von christlichen gruppen jimmy peres aus
nicaragua ist einer der migranten der
sein neues leben nicht illegal beginnen
will erwartet hier mit seiner frau
seinem baby seiner schwester und ihrem
kind auf die einreise in die usa
ich will nicht einfach über den fluss
ich will meine familie meine kinder
nicht gefährden
viele in dem lager warten hier seit
monaten viele sind verzweifelt denn ein
zurück in ihre länder ist unvorstellbar
doch es gibt alle paar tage auch dieses
migranten besteigen einen us
amerikanischen schulbus es sind menschen
die nach langer wartezeit ihre
einreisepapiere bekommen haben und so
ganz legal in die usa einreisen dürfen
die die zurückbleiben schöpfen hoffen
dass auch sie bald in diesem bus sitzen
und in die usa einreisen können
[Musik]